because as
a handful of teams play in the
postseason a handful of teams look for
new coaches and or general managers the
falcons don't yet have a general manager
although it's believed it will be terry
fontenot of the saints once the saints
season ends arthur smith of the titans
whose season ended this past weekend now
gets a job for the first time an nfl
head coach the son of fedex founder fred
smith making his own way in the world
going from nashville to atlanta shireen
as the head coach of the falcons your
immediate reaction
to the news that smith picked the
falcons and the falcons picked smith
well i think it's smart on the falcons
part to go with an offensive coordinator
mike and you've made this point and when
you pick a defensive coordinator as your
head coach which the falcons did last
time in den quinn
you're only as good as your offensive
coordinator and you see those guys leave
and this falcons team frankly hasn't
been the same since the super bowl they
haven't been the same since kyle
shanahan left for san francisco and
they've tried to duplicate that and they
haven't been able to do it they're still
going to build around matt ryan and if
you're going to build around matt ryan
he's your quarterback of the present and
the future then you have to get an
offensive coordinator so i think it was
smart to go the offensive coordinator
out mike
yeah and i do too i think if they had
hired kyle shanahan to be the head coach
the last time they hired a coach in 2015
kyle shanahan would still be the head
coach of the atlanta falcons at times i
feel like there needs to be a purge of
everyone that was associated directly or
indirectly with the 28-3 debacle against
the patriots a few years ago in the
super bowl short of selling the team
though that's not going to happen arthur
smith takes that job frankly if i'm
arthur smith i'll do respect falcons
that's not the job i want that's not the
best job right and it's not even close
in this cycle i would have wanted the
chargers job i would have wanted the
jaguars job although they locked on to
urban meyer we'll talk about that in a
second i'm just not sure that the
falcons job is the right job for me and
arthur smith feels like the kind of guy
for whom the door will still be open
next year if he had passed and i put the
falcons squarely in the wait till next
year category when i was ranking these
jobs last week if i'm arthur smith
i i definitely don't need the money i
can wait for the right opportunity i can
think about my legacy my chance of
success my chance of being in a place
long term and one of the concerns i have
about the falcons all due respect sorry
rich mckay but he's a former gm who's
now the team president it's a layer
between
me the gm and that and the owner of the
organization i'm not comfortable with
that i don't know what rich mckay's role
is going to be my guess is arthur smith
has gotten some representation about
what it'll be but whether that's what it
ultimately is who knows it's all very
vague and amorphous and it makes the job
less attractive not to mention the
salary cap problems not to mention
whether you want to keep julio jones and
or matt ryan maybe arthur smith has
other ideas we'll see how that goes
shireen but it's just another job that's
filled as the dominoes begin to fall we
went the full week right after the
season ended with none we added a
seventh on monday and now we see more
and more landing into place
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports